مع مرور الايام يتكشف حجم الضمار الهائل
الذي خلفه الزلزال في تركيا وجارتها
السهوله الاثنين
بعد ساعات من ذلك ثلاث الزلزال هزه
ارتداديه بلغت شدتها سبع درجات ونصف
الدرجه فحدث صدع كبير بسبب قوه التصادم
بين الصفائح التكتونيه الاناضوليه
والعربيه
المنطقه تقع على قمه خطوط الصدع الرئيسيه
وكثيرا ما تهتز بسبب الزلازل
هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه قالت ان
شده الزلزال الذي وقع قبل فجر الاثنين
بلغت سبعه درجات
وثمانيه اعشار الدرجه وكان على عمق 18
كيلومتر رقم يعني اطلاق كميه هائله من
الطاقه
شده الزلازل توازي طاقه المنبعثه من اكثر
من عشرين مليار كيلوغرام من المتفجرات
وهذا اقوى بما يقرب من الف مره من القنابل
الذريه لهذا لدينا مثل هذه الاضرار
الممتده في جميع انحاء المنطقه
شعر السكان بهزات ارتداديه كبيره منذ
الزلزال الاول ومع تحول الصفائح التكتونيه
لمحاوله ايجاد توازن جديد فان هذا النشاط
الزلزالي من المرجح ان يستمر لبعض الوقت
مما قد يتسبب في مزيد من الماسيد
للمحاصرين في مركز الزلزال
لدينا هنا منطقه هزات ارتداديه واسعه تبلغ
500 كيلومتر ونتوقع ان تحدث خلال الاشهر
المقبله هزات قويه على الاقل 20 زلزالا
بشده تفوق سته درجات ونصف مما يعني مزيدا
من الدمار وفقدان الارواح
تتدفق عروض تقديم الاغاثه من فرق البحث
والانقاذ الى الامدادات الطبيه والاموال
من عشرات البلدان اضافه الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وحلف شمال الاطلسي معظم
المساعدات لصالح تركيا مع وعد روسي وعربي
وكوري شمالي بمساعده الحكومه السوريه لكن
ليس من الواضحين اذا كان اي منها سيذهب
الى المناطق المنكوبه في الشمال الغربي
ظروف الشتاء تجعل جهود الانقاذ حرجه
للغايه
هذا زلزال مدمر انه بالتاكيد كارثه كبرى
ونحن نعلم ان الكثير من عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره
لكنه سباق مع الزمن لان توقعات بالنسبه
للمنطقه تشير الى طقس شديد البروده ولذلك
فان الذين كانوا من الممكن انقاذهم قد لا
ينجون بسبب الطقس
زادت عدد القتلى بسبب انهيار مئات المباني
مما ادى الى محاصره السكان تحت اكوام من
الانقاض وتخشى السلطات في سوريا ان يرتفع
عدد القتلى اكثر مع قيام رجال الانقاذ
بالبحث عن ناجين الدول المعدات المتخصصه
واشطى اكوام من الكتب المتشابكه من
الخرسانه والحديد في منطقه تعاني منذ اكثر
من عقد من الحرب وازمه النزوح